and I understand the an ethical reason
not to kill animals intentionally for
food but when you grow crops and you you
harvest those crops you're killing a lot
of animals I just remember very vivid of
just seeing like a nest of bunnies just
just there's no way around it I mean
when you're growing timothy hay for
example remove that or soybeans and
things like that there's tons of animals
that live there and when you have just a
pasture I mean the animals are free to
roam it's like perfect conditions I
could write you pictures I took on my
phone this morning the Spanish moss and
the cows love to eat this Manesh moss
and you know they're growing in the most
idyllic conditions and they're free to
roam and other things are in the pasture
and everything is growing crazy
especially when the rain starts it
becomes a incredible carbon carbon sink
and also rebuilding the soil too that's
part of it but prior to what we have now
it was intensively farmed heavily
treated with glyphosate GMO type crops
lots of fertilizer lots of chemicals
things like that so we're try we really
need to rebuild the soil so we just kind
of you know with the tractor just kind
of just moving the soil around planting
grass now just getting everything
growing so I think when it comes to like
food politics and what diet is optimal
for humans and some people may favor a
particular kind of diet
I think there's arguments on either side
you know what cuz when you talk about a
carnivore diet and you're talking about
concentrated feedlot operations so that
is a very that is very destructive to
what is it concentrated one like kay
foes when you have concentrated
agricultural kind of feeding Lots the
where the pigs chickens or cattle I mean
being the being the thing that's
probably most destructive they are put
into concentrated quarters and they're
basically and they're not they're not
fed grass they
come when they're born they may for the
first year so they may be in a pasture
but they're shipped off they're shipped
off to feedlot operations where all
their nutrition comes from sort of corn
and soy and they're there for stomach
system is not really designed to digest
assimilate and use this as an energy
source so you gotta give them like a lot
of antibiotics and they're concentrated
in areas where a lot of the manure and
everything there's significant runoff
and if this runoff is near crops then e
coli like can contaminate for example
the romaine lettuce or the the spinach
and things like that and then you have a
massive outbreak also you're more likely
to get a coli in from the food from this
type of feedlot operation because all
the food all the all the meat is mixed
together so if you have ground beef
you're eating beef from that package of
beef could be from hundreds of animals
right so if one is contaminated with
e-coli or another bug you are can
potentially contaminating a lot of
people whereas if you support like a
food co-op or a local small farm right
and you go there and you know I've
talked to many people who run these
farms I've watched many documentaries
right read many books no one gets sick
typically from these operations that
have been going on in the federal
government tries to crack down on them
because you know meat is supposed to be
USDA inspected and has to go through
certain the paperwork just to be an
organic function so you can buy on the
Shelf of Publix yeah just because to
like you know only a couple companies
really there's a couple companies that
monopolize this industry and the small
farms are taking away from that so the
federal government is actually it's
their bottom line right so there there's
a lot of partnerships like people for
these company
yeah they're on federal scientific
advisory boards and and they hold their
influential and the policies associated
with this but the small farms and we're
trying to be a hobby farm now yeah but
this like people listening really need
to go out and buy locally support small
farms and it's going to be better for
their health like overall but but really
important for the environment too and I
think you know if you go to a local farm
you know there it may be a little bit
more expensive like upfront but in the
long run I think it's going to save
everybody money you support these I
think food will eventually get a little
bit cheaper if policies start to
subsidize these smaller farms so it
really has to start with government and
I think a movement has already started
but I think maybe in the next five to
ten years government subsidies can help
out a lot of these smaller farms then I
think are going to be really essential
for building back the environment and
and and I think food will probably food
will be much better undoubtedly but I
think it'll it'll be more affordable too
because that's usually the pushback
well people can't afford right exactly
not convenient organic eggs are paying
three or four dollars a dozen but I
could go to Walmart and I think I can
get I get sixty eggs for like and I do
and I've done that for like four dollars
and fifty cents because we give our dogs
like eggs or somebody like that but when
we can I mean we try to support these
these smaller farms whenever possible I
think locally so we're trying to do that
more and we're trying to basically be
sustainable just on our farm you know
from an energy standpoint too with solar
panels and stuff like that oh that's
amazing
yeah we're so where do you get your eggs
my wife buys them now but we buy them
locally occasionally but they could be
as much as five dollars for a half-dozen
she goes she's a big she comes from
Europe and she's loves to shop at Aldi
so I'll take a certain stand
so which was because I was kind of get
on or buying like all this plastic and
stuff but we recycle everything but Aldi
has a new program now they're phasing
out all their packaging is going to be
like biodegradable oh wow the next
couple years so I mean they are usually
and it's like I think they're like
non-gmo like organic options and stuff
too and it was always kind of cheaper -
have you shopped at Aldi my house grab
box yeah yeah so we get a lot of stuff
from there occasionally we'll go to
Publix and stuff but like I said we get
a lot of the meat from some of these
companies like us wellness meats is
great we're eating their stuff now okay
put your box to butcher Buffy I'm pretty
good yeah and I think it's really hard
to find grass-finished like you can get
grass-fed but grass-finished a lot of
times what happens is cows will the last
month or two of their life they'll be
put on the feedlot they'll be raised
like their entire life and a pasture
right and so their pasture raised but
they'll be fattened up towards the end
and it does make them happy I mean you
could take some of the pellets and stuff
and you know I've taken a handful and
our cows I mean it's like candy and it's
like high-protein and it's like
everything but it's a mixture of grains
and things like that so we just try to
let them if we feed them if the pastures
not suitable enough like this time of
year is like the driest part now we're
getting into the rain season but we'll
just get some hay like a combination of
timothy and alfalfa and things like that
and spread it around okay and just make
sure you know we don't feed them corn or
how do you tell if it's crossed finished
or not
well it'll say it how it was I okay
butcher box is they have grass finished
okay and it's very hard to find if you
find it at the stores around here you
know sometimes I post and promote a
butcher box because some of the
affiliate links does come back and
support our research okay so I kind of
justify it with that but I also justify
that when they criticize it's not that
expensive it comes out to like $7 a
pound or $8 but it's really quality beef
and if you bought similar grass
finished beef at a store it would
probably be more it's just so hard in
mind you know but another thing is that
they have to the company sources some of
their beef from Australia so some of it
but they're now they're working with
small or they did about a year or two
ago because I was asking them where
they're getting their beef as a cattle
farm but I think they're working with
smaller farms now okay to basically you
know because it's becoming more popular
and the demand will kind of influence a
supply
[Laughter]